[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à dans les
studios du figaro on est en direct c'est
figaro live et on attend vos points de
vue en particulier sur la polémique
autour d'un éventuel couvre-feu en plus
du confinement on essaiera de comprendre
ce qui s'est passé depuis ce matin sur
cette annonce ou sept
ce rétropédalage on en profitera
également pour parler de la fronde des
évêques de france qui réclament le
maintien de la messe également on en
débat ce soir avec béatrice giblin
bonsoir béatrice géographe et rédactrice
en chef de la revue hérodote qui vient
de sortir son dernier numéro sur une
autre afrique médiane et avec un
éditorial de béatrice sur la
géopolitique de cette afrique médiane et
bien si vous voulez savoir en quoi ça
consiste
il faut se procurer le dernier numéro on
en débat également avec alexis brézet
directeur des rédactions du figaro
bonsoir allez vas-y dans le figaro qui
faisait sa une aujourd'hui qui revenait
sur le choc des deux amériques trump
hayden déjà 100 millions de votants et
en france on a choisi son camp on est
contre trump pour by donne alors est ce
que c'est votre choix est-ce que c'est
l'intérêt de la france également et bien
j'attends vos points de vue en tout cas
on en débat mais d'abord cette question
qu'on vous pose sur le site du figaro
faut-il un nouveau couvre-feu
faut-il ajouter un couvre-feu au
confinement si on pose la question c'est
d'abord et avant tout après avoir
entendu le porte parole du gouvernement
gabriela talent ce matin regard de ces
situations qui ont été observés nous
allons
ré instaurer un couvre-feu sur paris
peut-être l'île de france c'est le
ministre de l'intérieur qu'il précisera
dans la journée on arrêtait va sortir
précisément pour limiter un couvre-feu à
paris a eu comme il ya eu avant que le
confinement soit rendant plus en plus de
ce nouveau confinement sur quelle heure
le couvre-feu 21h je crois comme
le couvre-feu qui avait lu avant le
confie nantes
on vous a posé la question parce que ça
avait déjà été un peu étonné d'avoir
cette annonce parce qu'un peu plus tôt
on avait entendu le ministre de la santé
olivier vers en dire plus tôt ça les
chiffres attestent d'un respect du
confinement ryer par exemple les
chiffres de la baie les chiffres de la
ratp montré qu'on était à moins de 50%
de nos voyageurs dans les rames de métro
parisiennes le matin on est même tombé
par moments à seulement 20 à 25% du
nombre normal de clients en prenant les
transports en commun les chiffres du
télétravail atteste que les entreprises
jouent le jeu qui est salarié également
donc je crois le respect de ces gens
vivent normalement non par contre les
gens par rapport au premier confinement
emmènent leurs enfants à l'école peuvent
aller les chercher et peuvent aller
travailler
alors on vous a posé la question gay
lorsque un peu plus tard on à l'udc
selon matignon rien n'était en fait
acter et dans l'après midi
gabriel attal a rétropédalé déclaré en
fait que c'était le préfet de police de
paris qui a proposé qu'une mesures
soient prises pour restreindre les
horaires de certains établissements qui
donne lieu selon lui à des attroupements
sur la voie publique
c'est une proposition at il précisé qui
est actuellement en discussion avec les
élus locaux alexis plusieurs confrères
ont parlé de couac gouvernemental
est ce que c'est votre point de vue
bakou toute cette histoire on avait déjà
vu maintenant à l apo pin
on avait eu but c'était dans les
hypermarchés alors on va avoir droit
d'acheter du shampoing et pas voir leur
en acheter des du maquillage fois je
sais pas quoi toute chose totalement
absurde et technocratique et
bureaucratique bon c'était c'était
l'association jusqu'à ce matin dans ce
matin c'est le pompon du pompon alors
que monsieur verrando dit que le
confinement ça se passe plutôt bien car
ils alternent nous annonce un coût donc
un couvre feu alors qu'il ya quelques
jours on a arrêté le couvre-feu pour
faire le confinement parce qu'on nous a
dit que le coup fait que le couvre-feu
ça marchait pas donc on fait le
confinement et avant même d'avoir les
effets du confinement on nous rajoute
une couche
on ne rajouterai une couche de
couvre-feu et annonce aussitôt démentie
par le premier ministre on se demande
mais qui gouverne qui dirige qui
coordonne un peu caisse comme en gare et
à la tall qui pas un débutant
même s'il est très jeune va annoncer un
truc parce qu'il dit pas peut-être que
on envisage donné dit on va l'annoncer
c'est une mesure très précis cet ennemi
de l'intérieur qui va vous le dire qui a
dit à gré attal que c'était décidé pour
que apparemment minimiser la santé ni le
premier soit au courant tous est
tellement invraisemblable dans la dans
la méthode
comment on veut que les gens l'ont déjà
les gens consomment avoir assez c'est
donc tout ça c'est pas des bonnes
nouvelles et très casse pieds tout
donc ils ont déjà pas très envie mais
aussi en plus rares annonces des trucs
contradictoires tout travers et
incompréhensible il n'y a plus aucune
adhésion à toutes ces mesures si tous
est absurde
vatry je pense qu'il ya une panique sur
la montée très rapide du nombre de
malades ne sont pas l'hôpital est en
réanimation et elle s'est montrée
beaucoup plus vite encore
qu'on ne l'avait plus ou moins imaginer
et toutes les prévisions dit que le pic
sera la mi-novembre est peut-être une
encore une semaine après et que l'on
peut avoir dans les modélisations qu'on
ne fait pas en place si tu pasteur ou
d'autres on peut atteindre jusqu'à 9
1100 personnes en réanimation
quand on a été à 7000 en avril donc il y
à une wii ce jeu
ce type d'attitude où on annonce un
couvre-feu sur un confinement absolument
illogique puisque normalement être le
confinement ne peut sortir que dans
certaines conditions les enfants ils
sont rentrés d'école le soir y'a pas le
problème les on va pas aller travailler
dans l'est dans les usines ou ailleurs
de fait normalement le confinement
j'allais dire ne nécessite pas de couvre
feu ça a été dit sur eux sur paris parce
que je pense qu'à une pression
wade hospitalier il ya une pression du
personnel médical qui est extrêmement
inquiet avec en disant on pourra pas
vraiment mettre des gens ailleurs et on
a un personnel épuisé
il faut absolument que ça tienne je
crois que ça je ne suis pas du tout
gouvernement donc je ce que je dis est
une hypothèse mme mais je l'exprimé ça
normalement ce petit peu test peut tout
à fait soutient parce que ça doit être
vert ans qui depuis le début quand même
plus tôt le porte-parole des milieux
hospitaliers qui devrait tenir cette
thèse depuis le début c'est lui qui me
font toujours plus toujours plus hello
avait on nous dit pas finalement le
confinement ça se passe plutôt bien
les chiffres de la ratp montre que les
gens le respectent et c'est attal après
par rassemble été discrète mise à
l'intérieur le préfet de police qui nous
dit qu'ils me tient le discours il faut
réduire sinon ça semble pas pour des
raisons ses terres on a plutôt
l'impression vu le contexte c'est pour
des mesures d'ordre public c'est que
quand même si c'est le préfet de police
de paris d'allemands visa sera demandée
basescu on en arrivait aux hypothèses
vous êtes apparemment il ya ici ou là
alors est ce que c'est à paris est ce
que c'est en banlieue des gens qui ne
respectent absolument rien et donc on
est en train d'inventer de faire une
nouvelle couche pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir
bon on ne va pas puisqu'on est battu à
sont maintenant à mon avis maintenant on
la voit plus en sa part confirmé
officiellement ont dit on va en parler
oui parce qu'on ne veut pas faire un
rétropédalage alors sur le fond on la
fera plus est ce que vous disiez c'est
illogique mais sur le fond est ce que
finalement ça se discutait pas que
histoire d'être très dur très ferme de
cassé la courbe et d'ensuite de
desserrer l'étau
oui mais je sais rien de pire pour
l'autorité que d'être démenti par les
faits c'est qu'à un moment il faut
arrêter d'empiler des choses que les
gens ne respectent plus là on a un vrai
problème d'acceptation des mesures on le
voit dans un autre ordre avec la halle à
faire des petits commerçants on compte
quand des mères en grand nombre
d'extrême droite de droite
la reine de go je commençais à dire on
respectera plus loin c'est grave que des
mères disent on respectera tu dois faire
et donc ça veut dire quand on en vient à
ce point là c'est qu'on commence à voir
un refus d'accepter des règles et donc
le pour le pouvoir ce toutes ces règles
pour l'essentiel pourquoi les gens pack
pourquoi les directions respecter c'est
parce que les gens décident d'obéir
c'est tout ça repose sur des conventions
devant les gens en gros accepte quand on
dit vous faites ceci ils font ceci mais
si que les gens commencent à dire non il
n'y a pas les moyens de les obliger à
vous mettre un policier derrière chaque
chaque français chaque école chaque
commerçant et c'est donc ça devient très
compliqué donc il vaut mieux parfois
plutôt qu'en rajouter rajouter ajouté on
demande un tout petit peu moins faire en
sorte que soient respectés que toujours
plus toujours plus et faire en sorte que
plus personne n'oublie sais rien moi je
pense que enfin je crois qu'il serait
bon de rappeler que on a un mort toutes
les quatre minutes en ce moment que on a
un nombre d'hospitalisations un malade
qui rentre à l'hôpital toutes les deux
secondes que ça vient de donner des
chiffres très précis pour que les gens
se rendent compte du risque
on ferait quelques reportages en
floutant bien sûr sur ce qui se passe au
jour où d'interviewer des malades qui
sortent de réanimation qui vont mettre
des mois à s'en remettre pour que l'on
comprenne la nôtre ce qu'on fait qu'un
non pas assez à mon avis passe le plus
pressant
pas nous dire combien il ya vraiment
deux genres et de réanimation pur et dur
c'est à dire un tube et on n'arrive pas
à le savoir c'est quand même très
curieux on nous parle de soins
réanimatoires dans lequel on mélange la
réa tu veux dire on l'oxygénation
deuxième kateri troisième catégorie
l'observation et ça s'appelle soir annie
maintenant pourquoi les nous le dit pas
dans les 3000 qu'on a c'est pas tout
cela non pas les trois points dans les
dents les 6 e 5 6000 da mais non mais la
fin mois des chiffres que j'ai lu sur
réanimation proprement dit ces trois
militaires n'auraient jamais les vrais
chiffres
peut-être mais néanmoins néanmoins je
crois et il suffit de regarder tout
autour de l'europe
c'est un virus qui est extrêmement
contagieux du genre aux jeunes mois il
est extrêmement contagieux on l'a
complètement sous-estimé qui on en a eu
marre et on a espéré que bon voilà
c'était passé c'était derrière nous et
qu'on recommence et 2 on était dans
l'incapacité et julie on sait nous
l'ensemble des des français c'est pas
seulement les jeunes c'est l'ensemble
des français d'accepter qu'il fallait
encore faire attention
on a tous eu à paris et autour ou ou au
bord de la mer ou ailleurs ces terrasses
pleines de gens l'été fut très beau et
puis encore en septembre il suffit de
prendre le boulevard haussmann
quand on sort du figaro pour se rendre
compte moi j'étais effaré du nombre de
gens qui pouvait y avoir encore il n'ya
pas très très longtemps disant mais
qu'est ce qui se fait de changer comme
bien sûr heureusement que ça a changé
mais il a fallu elle est juste qu'on
continue mais pourquoi curieux pourquoi
est ce que on leur apprenait les seuls
aujourd'hui alors le royaume uni va nous
rejoindre d'ici deux jours à la belgique
non c'est pas un vrai confinement c'est
toujours non non ils sont chaque fois on
dit ça mais si on regarde dans le
tête-à-tête et moi je peux vous dire gm
veut qu'ils devaient venir il est
confiné peut pas venir ils à leur guise
le confinement les bruxellois ils sont
confinés enlever les arêtes couvre feu
de minuit à 5 heures du matin tu es
instauré dans tout pile un couvre feu
c'est pas la même chose
restaurants cafés bars pubs les cafés
les restaurants sont fermés
j'adore papoter libration possible
jusqu'à 22 heures vente d'alcool
interdite après 20 heures les
restaurants d'entreprise sont fermés
c'est là et on ne sait pas il n'y a pas
de confinement nationale et y en aurait
pas sortir de la belgique met donc à bah
oui
oui mais donc chacun pour renault avec
sylvie bah c'est pas de confinement pour
consulter pas de confinement
provencher a dans le sable pourquoi en
espagne il n'y en a pas en catalan et
madrid est confiné mot à dire c'est pas
vrai comme un couvre feu est imposé de
minuit à 6 heures alain couvre-feu en
catalogne c'est de 22 heures à 6 heures
pourquoi est-ce qu'en italie il n'ya pas
non plus de d'absolu confinement
nationale alors ça dépend un peu des
régions dépend des régions les
restaurants les cafés les bars peuvent
être couverts de 5 heures à 18 heures
les régions peuvent appliquer des
mesures plus respectives en fonction de
la situation sociale
pourquoi en allemagne c'est très curieux
pourquoi en allemagne je n'ai pas
l'ombre à berlin les rassemblements sont
autorisés dans des salles fermées
jusqu'à 1000 personnes des salles
fermées et dans des stands et dans des
lieux ouverts jusqu'à 5000 personnes à
vous m'étonnez énormément puel n'a pas
le droit d'être plus de quatre ou cinq
années en gueule alors qu'elle a ensuite
non non on a le droit ensuite ce qu'elle
a dit c'est qu'on a le droit de recevoir
des gens chez soi donc et pas du tout de
confinement de deux foyers c'est qu'on
peut inviter un autre ménage français 0
et c'est un coup vos viandes aco
finement on aura droit d'un don soir des
gens juste maintenant on est confiné en
allemagne en a le droit
donc tout ça pour dire et par ailleurs
il ya autant aucun de ces pays ce docu
fameux documents administratifs
quintessence du jeune et on sait il faut
cocher des croix le désormais juste
pourquoi à votre avis parce qu'on est
sans doute pas confiance dans le respect
des lois comme dans l'obéissance et dans
le glas conscience jaillir du collectif
voilà c'est à dire que je vois même avec
mes petits enfants j'ai du mal à leur
expliquer que d'accord eux
très bien mais il ya nous et que il nous
est bien que là vous pensez que donc en
français au fond ce régime se dit que
c'est la recette annuelle ce nom j'ai
dit que c'est la rose avant ça je veux
bien vous y est la représentation qu'on
en débat les italiens ils ont quand même
drôlement souffert beaucoup plus tout en
particulier la lombardie quand il y
avait tous ces cercueils qui
s'accumulaient congrès pas faire et
néanmoins même avec ça il faut re
réintervenir plus hein parce que je
prends la question d'haïti à ce que les
français sont plus indisciplinés jeu les
italiens
moi je ne le pense pas la preuve en est
c'est que dans le premier confinement ce
les français se sont comportés
c'est pour ça ce qui est sûr c'est que
quand on a dit à partir de septembre
attention attention personne n'a fait
attention à rien alors la sélection
puisqu'on parle du talent de comment les
italiens ont fait pensez vous pour
recruter six mille infirmières et 1400
médecin anesthésiste pendant l'été alors
qu'en france c'est zéro je ne veux pas
vous répondre parce que je le seul à
lezoux prix qu'ailleurs parce qu'ils ont
battu les former et très clair on ne
forme pas des anesthésistes en trois
mois
non on ne peut pas partir de zéro mais
on peut élever en compétence des gens
pas trop déjà en france
en france on vous dit zéro je ne pense
que vous avez tort parce que c'est pas
vrai - legrand est on là c'est dans le
nord on l'a fait écouter ce que j'ai vu
ce matin le patron des urgences de pau
qui lui dit chez nous c'est zéro j'ai vu
le patron de lariboisière il ya la
semaine dernière du chinois 0 je le
parle du grand est faible à 0 est ce que
moi j'ai entendu la directrice du pôle
de
hospitalier qui a dit on est monté en
puissance sur des infirmiers infirmières
qu'on a formé à en réanimation tout
l'été et c'est plusieurs centaines sur
le les hauts de france c'est pareil bon
vous êtes allé à pompidou et c'est sans
doute du vin qui a peut-être répondu que
non ou à salpêtrière ils ont peut-être
pas trouvé de gens pour le faire
ils sont pas peut-être que les gens
n'ont pas eu envie de me retourner
peut-être que il en sait qu'on a fait ce
qu'il fallait pour la suite on l'europe
voilà ça des campagnes de recrutement
qu'on aura pourquoi la télé traitement
apparemment on ya eu le ségur on a
avancé lors l'aurait augmentations de
salaire et on devait le faire plus tard
mais on le fait un peu plus tôt ça a été
fait dans le grotesque puisque moi je
n'ai entendu très clairement pour
l'europe bourgoin la personne aurait
raconté havrais raconter des
calembredaines bon avec des sons avec
plusieurs centaines de gens idem dans
une france où ça a été fait aux six mois
si les deux régions que je peux vous
citer je peux pas résister au niveau
global n'ont pas plus de vie dorée
accuse maintenant qu'on a de plus
certaines infirmières parce que oui oui
il ya les 162 kw à l'arrivée on a moins
de gens il ya beaucoup de fatigue
beaucoup de fatigue c'est pas mal pour
moi c'est d'un milieu médical chez moi
les chansons assez écoeurant
voilà on nous a applaudis rouge à
pleuvoir ils font n'importe quoi
ils ont même aucun respect de notre
travail et de ce conte et puis quand ils
seront malades
il faudra qu'on soit là pour ce pour
s'occuper d'eux c'est bien c'est pas
vis-à-vis du gouvernement que ça valse
est beaucoup plus à vis du comportement
des français par rapport à l'absence de
jaillir de sérieux avec lequel ils ont
pris cette cette pandémie
alors je rebondis sur ce que vous venez
dire ce que c'est la question avec les
poser sur le site du figaro est ce qu'il
faut un couvre-feu en plus du
confinement actuelle donc la question
est en ce moment est posée est pour
l'instant enfin quand on a commencé
cette émission est légère majorité en
tous les cas qu'ils étaient favorables à
cette restauration d'un couvre-feu très
légère majorité
c'est intéressant parce qu'on voit bien
il y a avant l'été quant aux demandes et
des mesures restrictives c'était 80 85 %
il sur la deux
qu'est ce site du figaro un qui passe
passe pas ce sondage il ya plus de
100000 parfois deux cent mille personnes
qui répondent tous à commencer on voyait
d'ailleurs c'était pas très loin des
sondages nationaux
quand on voyait que dès que les mesures
étaient restrictif ses 80 80 % de oui là
maintenant on est plutôt à 60 65 et la
voyez c'est ça sur la tuer ses 50 donc
on sent quand même que l'acceptation oui
parce que quand on annonce des mesures
mais qu'elles ne sont pas mises en place
vous voulez bien les accepter puisque
toute façon vous les subissent et bal à
partir du moment où elles sont mises en
place et où vous les subissent et à ça
change un peu
c'est parfaitement normal et non non je
vous parlais du premier confinement les
gens les subissent et toi non mais le
procédé était à fond le premier
confinement ça a été une telle
sidération d'accord mais là on
recommence dans une toute autre
perspective nous ne sommes plus au
printemps nous sommes à l'automne les
jours son cours on va être on a eu un
printemps ensoleillé comme ses limites
mais donc son gouvernement est confronté
à une la vision reste majoritaire mais
mais mais c'est beaucoup plus difficile
qu'on bâtit son commanditaire et il ya
été pardonné moi je me permets de vous
couper mais il ya dans la baisse des
adhésions aux mesures du gouvernement il
y a également une autre institution qui
vient de rentrer en viendront à l'aller
au créneau c'est les évêques de france
qui ont accepté d'en haut lors du
premier confinement l'interdiction des
offices religieux avec les messes
numérique
eh bien cette fois ci le président de la
conférence des évêques de france annonce
le dépôt d'un référé liberté au conseil
d'état après consultation de des autres
évêques qui sont réunis pour la
traditionnelle conférence des évêques de
france mais qui a lieu par
visioconférence en ce moment et il y a
eu également une tribune
auparavant dans le figaro d'autres
évêques de cinq évêques exactement de
plusieurs intellectuels dans ce sens
également l'art avant d'avoir votre
réaction je vous propose d'écouter ce
qu'on pense d'eux homme d'état à qui on
a posé la question jean pierre
chevènement et jean pierre raffarin
l'interdiction de la pratique des cultes
ne peut être que tout à fait
exceptionnel
je crois qu'elle pouvait peut-être
celui-ci fier pour la fed toussaint et
au moment où la france a été frappée par
plusieurs attentats
je pense que la règle c'est la liberté
des cultes
donc il faut revenir à cette bonne règle
c'est à dire une règle ou les églises
peuvent être peut-être ouvertes peuvent
être ouvertes quand on dit petit
commerce
le problème c'est petit c'est que on est
concentré sur peu de surface par
définition la taille de nos églises fait
qu'on peut pas parler de petite église
en france est encore en tout cas celles
qui seraient trop petit pour pourraient
être fermées mais à partir du moment où
on a cessé cathédrale ces bâtiments qui
sont d'une d'une immensité puissante je
pense qu'il ya vraiment au carré c'est
la responsabilité aujourd'hui
kiki à celle d'un état qui doit
respecter la vie spirituelle de ses
citoyens
était la vie spirituelle des citoyens
béatrice l'argument des évêques c'est à
dire qu'on peut limiter par exemple
notamment les jauges à 30% des places
disponibles à l'intérieur des édifices
religieux en clair une place occupée par
des fidèles deux autres sont condamnés
est ce que vous l'entendez cette arrivée
si on s'en tenait essentiellement aux
églises catholiques oui
le problème c'est qu'il ya les
évangélistes vous n'allez pas pouvoir
permettre seulement aux catholiques
d'aller à la messe vous avez tout le
problème des offices che les
évangélistes je vous rappelle que quand
même une des raisons de la gravité de ce
qui s'est passé dans le grand thèse ça a
été le rassemblement des évangélistes de
mulhouse
l'église de je sais plus comment elle
s'appelait où on a eu quand même
pendant cinq jours des gens qui étaient
par centaines voire même au delà du
millier à chanter est bon et qui sont
repartis chacun dans leurs mandants leur
région qui en corse qui au morbihan qui
est qui en guyane
donc le problème c'est pas effectivement
dans une grande église quand vous allez
vous et steimetz est d'ailleurs
suffisamment triste il ya 30 personnes
ça peut parfaitement se répartir mais
vous avez des petites salles
je pense par exemple en
seine-saint-denis où il ya pas mal de
san l'évangéliste petit avec énormément
de gens ou sachant tout ça bon ça parle
le fort donc on a beaucoup de postillons
et là il faut dire non bon donc à ce
moment là vous êtes obligés de traiter
tous les cultes de la même façon prima
facie pas tellement de raison par les
cadeaux les compétitions parce que on
leur dit avoir osé poser votre mais
c'est parce qu'il ya les évangélistes et
plus on leur dit il y avait aux écoles
non c'est bien qu'elle poserait problème
mais bon comme on apprenait que les
écoles musulmanes on va on va vous
embêter aussi enfin bon y'a pas toujours
de raison que cela les catholiques qui
paie pour les autres en l'occurrence si
on est capable pour les salles de
spectacles de mesurer des jauges en
fonction de la taille de la salle il n'y
a pas de raison qu'on ne soit pas
capable pour les mêmes en a fermé les
salles de spectacles aussi mais non au
logement pour la première fois lors de
premiers recours ce qui avait déjà eu un
recours devant le conseil d'état qui
avait été gagné par par des associations
catholiques c'était justement parce que
c'était deux poids deux mesures et
certains rassemblements et d'autoriser
et cela ne l'était pas mais en tout cas
en l'occurrence si on est capable de
dire dans cette façon sans dire tel type
de religion petit très bien dire que
deux
on se débrouille en garde s'il atteint à
partir de temps on a droit puis si tu es
trop serré on n'entre pas il suffit de
mettre en jeu
c'est vrai que la liberté de culte est
quand même une des toutes d'ailleurs
reconnu comme tel par le conseil
communal à chaque fois et le conseil
d'état à chaque fois toute première mais
diverti fondamental démocratique dire
que là on est quand même dans un an on
parle de lois d'exception d'état de
droit et compagnie la la suspension de
la liberté de culte c'est quelque chose
de jamais vu en france depuis quand
depuis la révolution française
voilà je sais pas si pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale en zone occupée on se
précipitait à l'église bah non pas au
moment des bombardements
non mais moi je pense en ce moment si
vous voulez on est sur une situation où
la contamination flambe un voile a
raconté un village une équipe de foot 40
contaminés est ce que c'est on est sûr
sûr sûr un moment comme ça alors on peut
se dire aussi qu'on peut avoir un peu
conscience des difficultés et des enjeux
et du respect pour les hospitaliers et
tout évêque conçoit expliqué que pendant
un mois 4 dimanche
eh bien on suivra la messe à la
télévision comme des cas de malades le
fond les malades et ben ils peuvent pas
aller à l'église et on leur interdit
quand même pas le culte et ils peuvent
continuer à prier
donc ça me semble pas absolument
essentiel dans un moment aussi non mais
bien sûr qu'aux non mais je sais bien
mais c'est qu'il ya le moyen de suivre
la même apparaître du tout des gens la
même chose
c'est sans doute pas la même chose mais
à un moment j'allais dire de communautés
où la situation est grave et bien on
demande un effort à tout à chacun et on
demande un effort aux croyants quel
qu'il soit pendant quatre semaines je
sois le vendredi que ce soit le très
bien que c'est pas quelques semaines ça
va être pour l'instant et passera
peut-être jusqu'à noël
et s'ils veulent aller à la baisse 2008
mais il faut se tenir tranquille jusque
là sinon ils n'auront pas de noël
non tu l'appelles ou suspension des
libertés démocratiques mais est ce qu'on
verra si le conseil constitué de quoi
détendre à l'examen l'examen du référé
est prévue jeudi matin à 1 heure et
demie de mémoire un couvre-feu alors
qu'il y à déjà le confinement ça ne sert
à rien à quel intérêt nous dit si thomas
choqué de voir qu'une majorité de gens
est favorable à l'instauration d'un
couvre-feu en plus du confinement alors
lui il est adepte de la méthode suédoise
la suède met jamais mis en place de
telles mesures est enregistrée peu
demeure comment ça se fait c'est un
autre débat
le qu'on arrête avec cette propagande de
la peur nous dit kris kross chardons
bleus se demande si olivier warrants lui
est crédible et
nous avons également si tu qu'il dit
pourquoi nous confiner instaurer des
couvre-feux si nos enfants peuvent être
à 30 par classe à l'école et chardons
bleus estime l'icg les messes ne sont
pas indispensables les églises seront
elles toutes surveillées demande-t-il là
encore un autre débat je vous propose
qu'on regarde une autre question en
attendant puisque ce débat est sans fin
et qu'on risque de la voir dans les
semaines d'aller semaines encore à venir
par contre ce
ce débat je suis pas sûr qu'on puisse le
multiplier à l'infini quel est votre
regard sur le match trump d'haydn calé
vous internautes votre choix en tout cas
à la question souhaitez-vous donald
trump soit réélu président des états
unis sur le figaro vous avez été
nombreux à répondre et nombreux à
répondre non donc plus de 200 mille
réponses en tout et une majorité donc de
réponse non 62 3% très exactement et au
niveau national c'est encore plus marqué
puisque sondage concarnois 5% de nos
galas du figaro est pas tout à fait
l'unisson de l'opinion française elie
sûr donc qu'il souhaite élections de jeu
werden à l'image de l'ancien ministre
d'ailleurs de l'intérieur de la défense
le sondage le sondage national c'est à
vous une bonne et une mauvaise opinion
il ya également la même alors il m'avait
semblé devoir qui avait le souhait
également alors souhaité vous pas rendre
souhaitez-vous 80 de donner un trône de
dryden 80 de bagdad - 2 % et 15 au
centre alors par m
parmi ces 80 2% et des médias 4 paris
c'est 80 de poisson par lydia jean
pierre chevènement je n'y arrivais côté
visiblement on peut penser qu ici
monsieur byden était élu ça facilitera
les choses du point de vue de l'accord
sur le climat ont tiré parti sont ou
bien sûr lire ont peut-être qu'on
pourrait revenir une position plus
raisonnable c'est-à-dire la
dénucléarisation de l'iran une telle
qu'elle avait été négocié maintenant sur
d'autres sujets en particulier les
rapports avec la chine et les rapports
avec l'europe
je pense qu'il ne faut pas trop attendre
de l'évolution de la politique
américaine
je crois que pour des raisons de fond
les états unis regardent de plus en plus
vers le pacifique vers la chine de moins
en moins vers l'europe
par conséquent nous ne faisons pas trop
d'illusions alors n'attendons pas des
autres ce que nous devrions entend
d'abord de nous mais ge
béatrice je fais cette eau n'est que
jean pierre chevènement un chantre du
souverainisme du souverainisme de gauche
soit assez favorable avec si on a un
homme comme by donne qui souhaitent le
maintien de l'otan et
un resserrement de l'alliance atlantique
et c'est bien triste mais c'est pas un
imbécile
il est souverainiste il a été ministre
et il est capable de faire une analyse
je pense quand même que la politique
étrangère de trump même s'il a eu à dire
d'une certaine façon l'audace de dire
très fort et tout ce qui se passait
vis-à-vis de la chine peut-être bon et
que ça tout le monde au fonds lui en
sais gré je dois dire d'une certaine
manière
ceci étant ces événements qui est quand
même un homme d'état c'est très bien que
la politique imprévisible de trump est
un peu chamboule tout il lance la balle
et puis on va voir ce qui se passe et
tout à fait problématique l'otan il
essaie vainement il sait très bien que
la france toute seule elle peut pas
rivaliser et assurer sa défense
totalement on a augmenté un peu bêtement
sur le budget de la défense mais ils
avaient été réduits pendant très très
longtemps
les etats unis restent quand même et de
lourds commençaient ce cheveu de mon
exact e mans est de loin le premier
trait au budget de la série qui est
encore bien plus fort que celui de la
chine qu'on a du mal à évaluer très
précisément d'ailleurs sans doute plus
élevé que ce que ce qu'ils veulent bien
le dire donc et puis je pense qu'il se
rend compte aussi que la situation avec
un retrait des états unis oubli ge et
qu'on n'est plus du tout dans la
configuration des années 80 ou 90
c'est le lot a coulé et que la défense
redevient une question importante est
que à la limite une europe de la défense
ce peut-être qu'ils seraient pas contre
30 nous dit nicole n'est pas trop
politiquement correct mais perso bailon
me fait un peu peur pour ce que les
américains vont encore nous imposer cib
hayden est élu avec si je veux pas vous
demander pour qui vous votez on n'est
pas américain mais quel regard vous
spécialiser politique française
vous portez sur cette élection et puis
sur la polarisation qui a la crainte
également des émeutes
en tous les cas ce qu'on annonce
qu'on craint pour l'après-élection alors
si c'est sur la politique française
c'est tout à fait non c'est tout à fait
une autre question n'est plus du tout
dans les conséquences directes
je suis d'accord ce qui est dit sur la
question de l'europe et du
multilatéralisme
trump ne fait a essayé de faire sauter
toutes les institutions multilatérales
et nous en europe on ya intérêt
puisqu'on n'a pas la puissance on a
intérêt ce qu'on parle quand on est les
plus forts on peut dire on parle pas
c'est pas grave nous quand on n'est pas
fort on a besoin de parler donc tout ce
qui met en cause les systèmes ont parlé
mauvais pour nous donc de ce point de
vue l'europe a plutôt intérêt à ce que
ça va mais après si maintenant on
s'intéresse à l'effet politique à
l'impact politique de 2,2 d'une victoire
ou de bagdad où notre homme en france
c'est plus c'est plus un jeu de deux
scénarios
qu'est-ce qu'on peut se dire c'est qu'au
fond là le trump isme est une espèce de
ferments de comment dire de levier
autour de qu'elle va s'articuler en
france par analogie la bataille macron
le pen au fond la victoire de tram c'est
la victoire des méchants populiste et
donc ça permet à macro de dire
empêcheront les méchants populiste en
france de triompher et ça permet à
marine le pen disons donne enfin la voix
au peuple et donc de ce point de vue si
le titre up était battu ça serait
évidemment pas une bonne nouvelle en
france pendant l'open puisque de
dynamique auto ça serait pas forcément
non plus une bonne nouvelle sur le plan
de la politique française je parle pas
sur le plan des deux de leurs leaders la
scène à la france d'un fonds national
etc
je pense qu'ils s'en réjouirait mais sur
le plan de la politique intérieure
française pour macron parce que du coup
on sortirait de cette polarisation entre
populiste d'un côté anti populiste de
l'autre et toutes choses qui le sert lui
l'intérêt à ce à ce choc-là donc au fond
c'est un paradoxe
et je ne suis pas du tout en train dire
qu'ils souhaitent une victoire de twente
mais on pourrait dire que politiquement
il aurait plutôt intérêt à une victoire
de truffes trump réussi à faire en
conseillant à l'épouvantail il a besoin
d'épouvantail trump a réussi à faire
passer by donne pour un dangereux
gauchiste alors que le programme de
baden c'est celui de juppé nous dit
edwards quand on voit quand même les
soutiens de bail donne quand même cédé
soutien qui sont surtout toute la
tendance qu'on appelle la tendance aux
hawks et à tendance éveillé
mais de l'huile sur le feu sur un
certain nombre de pelé idéologique on
n'a pas l'impression que ces problèmes
de juppé quand même non mais faut entre
ce qui se dit pendant une campagne
électorale commence joue de façon
médiatique comment il faut comme on dit
faire le buzz comme en bas après une
fois que vous êtes au pouvoir il d'abord
il va falloir quand même la chambre des
représentants ils vont sans doute la
regarder toute la question c'est le
sénat est ce que il ya trois voix
d'avancé au sénat alors apparemment il
est possible que j ai cinq ou six
sénateurs démocrates qu'ils soient élus
auquel cas ça ferait basculer mais ça
peut être jusque 4 auquel cas où on est
la vraie femme peut-être avec deux de
sénateurs dont on ne pourra pas dire
tout de suite ils seront tellement
égalité qu'il faudra revoter
donc tout ça nous amène en janvier donc
baidhani s'il veut faire un ca de la
nombre de choses il est obligé d'avoir
les deux chambres avec lui bon s'il n'en
a qu'une file sénat reste républicain sa
marge de manoeuvre sera beaucoup plus
petit
bon donc moi je ne m'attends absolument
pas avec bayonne à avoir un
bouleversement et avoir tout d'un coup
un basculement
on va dire ceux des états unis vers le
socialisme je n'y crois absolument pas
et personne n'y croyait même pas ce qui
s'est alors vers ce me semble qu on ne
peut pas croire non plus qu'une élection
de beille d'inde résoudrait par miracle
tous les problèmes les problèmes et
notamment ce fossé qui fracturent
l'intérieur de la salle de la mairie que
la sentra d'éthique qui est effrayant
c'est que c'est plus du tout la gauche
contre la droite en plus la protéine
société civile a armé des deux côtés
avait tout d'un côté comme les émeut
dans l'armée
non pas c'est que je vous plains les
afro-américains personnel qui s'arme en
ce moment mais en se disant si jamais
c'était de gagner il faut concevoir mais
il a là quand vous avez vu l'attitude de
30 pour demander l'asile moment du
bassiste blanc je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez de ces de ce passage avec quand
même quelqu'un qui charger une foule
avec sa voiture et le président kidiaba
wii est de la violence et de côté ses il
ya eu on a attisé cette polarisation de
fa il a attisé de façon massive enfin
sans respect du tout de ce que doit être
un président d'une nation comme qui est
quand même les états unis c'est quand
même une grande nation
j'ai trouvé étions absolument divine
mais quoi qu'il en soit que le site rump
été battu le ce fossé et qu'ils
reconnaissent déjà sa descendance de la
pagani
mais en tout cas ce cette fracture
sociologique idéologie politique
philosophie culturel qui états unis elle
va rester et est peu ou prou alors à des
degrés moindres à des degrés avec
heureusement beaucoup moins d'intensité
c'est comme une fracture qui se retrouve
dans tous les pays occidentaux entre les
élites et les peuples entre les la
france périphérique et la france des
centre-villes tout ça c'est quelque
chose ça c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
absolument éviter mais qui nous dit que
duquel que l'eau du ciel à venir de nos
pays les états unis donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose qu'il faut méditer
c'est pour ça que on a posé la question
ce soir à travers sa wii vous dira je
veux dire que le trump n'est pas arrivé
par hasard
le produit de cette phrase exacte il a
attisé vous avez raison il en remet un
départ à vélo
il est arrivé parce qu'il y avait sept
alors sur sur les armements ben frej ou
recommande un très beau reportage en
californie ou même des california
pacifiste maintenant vont acheter des
armes c'est un reportage à lire à
retrouver sur le site du figaro armel
vincent qui est
ne pigez sur place et puis il y a
également tous les récits notamment à un
longue lecture par michèle tribalat d'un
livre de mike gonzalez gonzalez qui
raconte également comment la gauche
américaine a également s'est
métamorphosée et comment le concept des
minorités s'est imposé dans l'est dans
les années récentes
on va y revenir dans ça fait déjà un
moment dans le récent de l'étude depuis
des années 60 depuis depuis la politique
de discrimination positive
euh bon je suis désolé de cette facilité
mais ce que vous avez un pronostic
finalement sera optimisé avec si vous
gérez de produits que la veille alors
vous aurez les résultats
j'ai envie d'y croire vous aurez
peut-être les résultats demain à 6
heures en tous les cas on est en direct
vais rester sur le carreau millions de
gens qui ont déjà voté oui 100 millions
déjà voté c'est à dire que ça veut bien
dire l'enjeu pour les américains de
cette élection
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
extrait et les parties ait puisque c'est
le think thank you mobilisation donc que
c'est les patrons de bayonne qui votent
et les présentera me dit c'est le signe
que depuis le début on dit que votre
homme caché qui est en train de se
révéler moi je ne crois pas aux autres
trucs cachés et demain on va voir ça non
on espère on espère le voir dès
commencer par ailleurs il comme n'aura
comme le maintien
on espère commencer à le voir dans les
prochaines heures dans tous les cas nous
on se quitte sa minute par minute sur le
site du figaro on est en direct sur en
live texte
donc pour tous maintenant et toute la
nuit et demain matin et on sera
également en live vidéo dès 6 heures du
matin pour commenter analyser les battre
sur le site et sur le pdf à 5 heures du
matin 6 heures du matin et 7 heures du
matin en fonction des vous montrera les
unes également en vidéo et bien sûr vous
les aurez accessible sur le site pour
nous en vidéo on se retrouve dès 6
heures mais vous quittez pas le site du
figaro parce qu'on est déjà en direct
donc garder un oeil dessus tout l'âge
toute la soirée toute la nuit et demain
toute la journée et on répondra à vos
commentaires à vos réactions donc je
vous dis pas à demain puisque vous
restez sur le site du figaro a très vite
[Musique]